trois barbecues six cuisiniers et un
jury lundi de juillet la ferme de la
petite aux gars auffargis a pris des
allures de top chef éric sens aux
agriculteurs et amoureux du terroir a
organisé la première compétition de
burgers slow food
un mouvement qui vise à sensibiliser au
mariage entre gastronomie et écologie
c'est un événement pour mettre en valeur
les avants des carcasses parce que bien
souvent les bouchers ne veulent
travailler que les arrières des
carcasses et non pas les avants c'est
une vache de la maison nourris
uniquement à l'herbe et au point dans
les meilleures conditions que des
produits locaux des fruits des légumes
qui viennent qui viennent du coin
locales aussi chez les participants
chefs étoilés comme frédéric l'arc
humain du trianon palace à versailles ou
maîtres restaurateurs comme christophe
cornier de l'auberge de l'élan mais
aussi des nouveaux venus
christophe parents a ouvert son
restaurant il y a trois ans c'est
essayer de rivaliser avec des grog
mais ya pas de prétention donc le but
c'est d'être dans le good de départager
des choses un généreuse j'ai fait un
burger qui était généreux kippa
pointilleux com ou raffiné mais il ya du
goût et de la saveur c'est ça qui est
intéressant
moi je suis parti sur un burger on vire
le burger 78 7 à 8 ingrédients on va
dire voilà donc on est sûr tout vient de
la petite boutique
derrick et donc on a le du cochon la
poitrine de cochon fumée on avait la
viande de boeuf de salers forcément à
une tomme de brebis des ses bêtes du
radis noir une sauce au poivre donc
assez rustique dans le jury présidé par
stéphane chicherit directeur de l'école
lenôtre difficile de désigner un gagnant
les six candidats sont arrivés ex-aequo
tous très très différents les gars
avaient bien joué je donc des saveurs
très différente des très traditionnelle
des limites asiatique des mystères
années un certain m travailler avec
autre chose que du pain donc très
intéressant avis aux gourmands les
burgers créés pour l'occasion seront à
retrouver sur les tables des
restaurateurs un autre événement slow
food avec de la viande de gibier cette
fois aura lieu cet automne